there's a public thesis defense Matt
Hammer is a second year Master's student
in the bioinformatics and computational
biomedicine program here at OHSU and
he'll be graduating this term upon
completion of this presentation and
following exam he started his degree in
2021 after graduating from the
University of Vermont with a Bachelor of
Science in biology his interests are in
bioinformatics and computational biology
and it stems from his passion in
investigating the multi-factorial nature
of human health and disease
along with his coursework and his thesis
Matthew Works in my lab as a student
worker and he's been assisting me with
some of my research focused on the
urinary and gut microbiomes in relation
to human health in the future he hopes
to continue exploring the causative role
of commensal microorganisms in human
health and disease and with that I will
turn it over to Matt
hello everyone my name is Matt and this
is my public oral thesis defense for my
project entitled the evaluation of
functional inference tools for the
Pediatric gut microbiome Lisa Carstens
is my thesis advisor and the remaining
members of my thesis advisory committee
are Michael Mooney and Jenny Johnstone
here's a brief outline of what I'm going
to go through in today's presentation so
I'll start with an introduction to the
gut microbiome and then address some
backgrounds and aims for the specific
projects go over the materials and
methods that were used I then talk about
results and discuss those results
the gut microbiome refers to the
naturally occurring microorganisms that
live within the guts of all animals
including humans
the gut microbial Community is comprised
of bacteria fungi viruses and
bacteriophages as well as Archaea and it
contributes to the vital human functions
including metabolism and Immunity among
others
the gut microbiome's composition is
highly variable between individuals as
well as highly variable within
individuals at different times this
makes it very difficult to pinpoint a
healthy or normal composition however
the more diverse the community is the
more stable and resilient that Community
is to change and this is important
because altered gut microbiome
composition has been associated with
various different disease States
including metabolic disorders
Neuropsychiatric disorders
inflammatory disorders and certain
cancers among others
major colonization of the Pediatric up
microbiome begins at Birth and continues
until
um to develop until the onset of puberty
and there are many factors that impact
the colonization of the gut microbiome
and these factors include mode of
delivery breastfeeding status
gestational age at Birth and exposure to
antibiotics among others
these differences in the colonization
have widespread effects both during
colonization and later in life
making studying the Pediatric gut
microbiome having a potential to
illuminate various aspects related to
lifelong human health and disease
since the colonization begins at Birth
and the composition continues to develop
until the onset of puberty we see a
decreased diversity in the Pediatric of
microbiome compared to the adult gut
microbiome and this plot here shows
this plot shows the specific microbial
taxa that are differentially expressed
in the Pediatric and adultha microbiomes
where orange represents those microbes
that are enriched in the Pediatric
population in the study and green
represents those microbes that are
enriched in the adult population from
the study
well this is a helpful graphic for
visualizing the differences in the P um
between the Pediatric gut microbiome and
the adult gut microbiome their lacks a
consensus for specific differences in
microbes present between these two
populations and
um this isn't largely due to heterogeney
between individuals and within
individuals at different time points as
well as between different populations
it's very difficult to replicate the
composition of the gut microbiome in a
lab so we rely on sequencing techniques
to identify the composition of the gut
microbiome these sequencing techniques
can broadly be broken down into two
categories first being the amplicon
based sequencing which targets specific
regions of the genome known as marker
sequences or amplicons
and the second is shotgun based
sequencing which sequences all desire
genetic material in a sample
of these sequencing techniques to our
most popular
in research in the gut microbiome and
this is 16s ribosomal RNA amplicon
sequencing which I'll refer to as 16s
RNA for the rest of the presentation
and shotgun metagenomic sequencing which
is also known as whole genome shotgun
sequencing and I'll refer to this as wgs
for the rest of the presentation
there are some differences in
methodology that are taken by these two
sequencing techniques so 16s right RNA
sequencing targets the 16s ribosomal RNA
subunit Gene and this is found in
bacteria and Archaea and this Gene is a
perfect candidate for marker Gene
sequencing or amplicon sequencing as it
um
as conserved regions that are flanked by
hypervariable regions and the conserved
regions can be used as targets for
primers of amplify for amplification
whereas the hypervariable regions can be
used to differentiate between specific
microbes
as opposed to wgs which sequences short
fragments from all DNA present in the
sample
these differences in methodology reflect
key differences in outputs so first
being 16s RNA captures bacteria and
archaea only and this is because as I
alluded to this Gene is only present in
bacteria and archaea whereas wgs is able
to capture all different domains because
we are sequencing short fragments from
all DNA present
16s RNA sequencing also has limited
taxonomic resolution and we can really
only assign taxonomy reliably down to
the genus level whereas for wgs we can
assign taxonomy to sequences down to the
species or even strain level if desired
third 16s RNA does not provide
functional information and this is
because 16s RNA sequencing is only
capable of profiling the taxonomic
composition and does not give any
information about the metagenome
composition
and while all these differences point to
the use of wgs for investigating in the
gut microbiome wgs can be very expensive
and time consuming which can be very
prohibitory for certain investigations
to make up for the shortfalls of 16s RNA
sequencing we can use metagenomic
inference to infer the metagenome
content of a microbial Community Based
on its taxonomic composition and this
relies on the notion that phylogeny is
strongly correlated with biomolecular
function and therefore it's possible to
predict functional composition of a
microbial communities metagenome from
its taxonomic composition
there are two common approaches for
metagenomic inference the first being
the reference phylogenetic tree based
approach and in this approach reference
sequences are or environmental sequences
are placed into a reference phylogenetic
tree containing sequences for known
microbes with complete genomes
the genomes associated with each
sequence are determined based on the
placement of the sequence within the
reference phylogenetic tree and
metagenomes are constructed by
aggregating all genomes associated with
sequences identified in a sample
the other common approach to pan genome
construction-based approach and here pan
genomes for each microbe identified in a
sample are generated by combining all
genomes from microbes in the reference
data set that have the same microbial
taxa
and in a metagenome for this is
constructed by aggregating all pan
genomes associated with each micro
present in a sample
so to summarize what I just went over
and this serves as my motivation for my
project
16s RNA is only capable of profiling
taxonomic composition and thus does not
provide any information about functional
capacity of the environment whereas wgs
is capable of profiling both taxonomic
composition and metagenome composition
however wgs is much more expensive than
16s RNA and this can be very prohibitory
for certain investigations
functional inference or metagenomic
inference offers a cost-effective
alternative to wgs for exploratory
analyzes and can be really helpful for
researchers to orient them towards their
expected results
there has been some previous
benchmarking done on tools for
metagenomic inference in the past
however this previous benchmarking did
not include the Pediatric gut microbiome
and as I've said the Pediatric gut
microbiome is known to vary
significantly from that of the adultha
microbiome and we can't necessarily rely
on these results being applicable to
this environment
and this led me to propose the following
specific aims for my project the first
being to compare popular tools for
metagenomic inference specifically in
the context of the Pediatric gut
microbiome and using the results that I
attained from my first aim my second aim
was to establish a framework for
choosing a functional analysis strategy
that best suits the needs of different
projects as a means for informing
researchers who hope to do functional
analysis of the Pediatric gut microbiome
on their options when it comes to
functional analysis
and I'll go over the materials and
methods that were utilized in this
investigation
this investigation utilized publicly
available data that was downloaded from
the ncbi SRA database or X sequence read
archive and to be included in this
investigation the data sets needed to
meet some specific requirements this
being that the sequences needed to be
from pediatric fecal samples and for
each sample we needed to have paired 16s
RNA and wgs data present and finally for
the 16sr and a sequencing this needed to
Target the V4 hyper-variable region to
ensure consistency across all data sets
we ended up with three data sets that
met these requirements the first being
the diab immune studies antibiotics
cohort and this contained 39
individuals or subjects from Finland
the second data set came from a study
that evaluates differences in gut
microbiome development based on
gestational age at Birth and we termed
this as the gestational age cohort and
this data set contained 41 subjects from
New Zealand
the final data set we included here was
a subset of samples in the resonance
cohort specifically collected at the
second time point and this contained 41
samples from children in Providence
Rhode Island
next couple slides go over a demographic
breakdown for these specific data sets
we'll start with diab immune the
diademium cohort contained 22 males and
17 females with an average age of 1.8
years old and subjects in this cohort
were either assigned to the antibiotics
test group or the control test group
based on whether or not they received
antibiotic intervention during the
course of the study
the second data set was the gestational
age cohort and this contained 23 males
and 18 females with an average age of
7.9 years old and subjects in this
cohort were either assigned to the very
preterm or full-term test groups where
very pre-term correlates to birth at
less than or equal to 32 weeks of
gestational age whereas the full term
corresponds to birth during the normal
range for gestational age at Birth which
is 37 to 41 weeks
finally for the residence cohort this
cohort contained 21 males and 20 females
with an average age of 5.2 years old and
this study the study from which this
data set was derived followed healthy
individuals so there weren't test groups
assigned to subjects in this data set
when we downloaded the information but
we to support different analyzes in this
investigation that relied on comparisons
between test groups I assigned test
groups to each subject based on whether
or not they were older or younger than
the median age of samples collected at
that time and that median age was five
years old
so now I'll run through a conceptual
model for the
methods that I used during this
investigation
I started out with paired data and I
extracted the 16s RNA and wgs data
next I process the raw data to ensure
that no Downstream results were impacted
by differences in processing and I
process these each according to their
respective processing pipeline so for
16s RNA this consisted of ASV analysis
that identifies relevant sequences
followed by taxonomic assignment where
taxonomy was assigned to all the
sequences that were identified
for wgs processing consisted of sequence
cleaning followed by taxonomic
assignment
so the result of processing was
taxonomic composition for each of these
types of data and to get the metagenome
composition for each data type
metagenomic inference was carried out
for 16sr RNA whereas functional
assignment was carried out for wgs
metagenome predictions and metagenomic
inference was carried out using three
different tools so paprika pie crust 2
and pan FP whereas wgs functional
assignment was carried out using human
three
metagenome profiles here serve as the
ground truth or the gold standard for
metagenome content in a sample
here metagenome predictions and profiles
consisted of Gene abundance tables where
genes were listed on the y-axis with
samples represented on the x-axis and
each value in the prediction or in the
gene abundance tables reflected the
abundance of a specific Gene in that
specific sample
so metagenome predictions and profiles
were generated based on two different
genome annotation types EC numbers which
reflect entries in the enzyme
commissions database nko terms which
represent entries in The Keg orthologies
database and my reasoning for this was
that paprika's default reference
database is based on EC numbers whereas
pan FPS
default reference database is based on
KO terms
and there's an issue of multi-mapping of
ko terms to EC numbers where multiple KO
terms will map to the same EC number and
this main mapping between annotation
annotation types very difficult so we
decided to just keep these separate
because pie crust 2 was able to generate
um
was able to generate genome predictions
or metagenome predictions in terms of
multiple different types of genome
annotations including both EC numbers
and KO terms and human three as well was
able to generate metagenome profiles in
terms of multiple different genome
annotation types including KO terms and
EC numbers
so once we have the metagenome
predictions and metagenome profiles we
were able to carry out benchmarking
analysis which consisted of comparing
metagenome predictions to metagenome
profiles and then comparing the results
between inference tools this means that
EC predictions were compared to EC
profiles whereas KO predictions were
compared to KO profiles resulting in pie
crust 2 being compared to Paprika in
terms of EC numbers and pie crust 2
being compared to pan FP in terms of ko
terms
benchmarking analysis in this
investigation can be broken down into
three different analyzes first being
performance analysis followed by
differential abundance agreement
analysis and finally an analysis of the
computational resource requirements of
each tool and I'll go into more detail
about these in the results section
so let's start with performance analysis
performance analysis consisted of
calculating six different metrics the
first being spearman's correlation which
evaluates the association between
predictions in the ground truth which
are metagenome profiles and here's
spearman's correlation was used as
opposed to Pearson's correlation since
we're dealing with a non-linear
monotonic relationship between two
non-parametric vectors
all butt spearman's correlation are
actually classification evaluation
metrics that were applied to this
investigation and I'll go into more
detail about how these were calculated
in the next couple slides
so by converting Gene abundance tables
in metagenome predictions and profiles
to Binary where zero represents the
absence of a gene and one represents the
presence of a gene and any Gene with an
abundance greater than zero was
considered to be present
we can treat metagenomic inference as a
classification task and since we can
treat it as a classification task we can
use classification evaluation evaluation
metrics to evaluate the performance of
metagenomic inference and classification
evaluation metrics are calculated based
on values in a confusion Matrix which is
represented here and this Matrix
contains counts for instances of
agreement and disagreement between
predictions and the ground truth in this
table true refers to agreement between
predictions in the ground truth whereas
false refers to disagreement between
predictions in the ground truth
and positive refers to the present
predictions whereas negative refers to
absent predictions
this means that the true positive count
is the number of genes that were
identified as being present in both the
metagenome predictions and the
metagenome profile whereas the true
negative count is the opposite of this
or the number of genes that were
identified as being present in both the
metagenome predictions and the
metagenome profile
on the other hand the false positive
count is the number of genes that were
predicted as being present but were
identified as absent in the metagenome
profile whereas the false negative count
is the opposite of this or the number of
genes that were identified
or that were predicted as being absent
but were identified as present in the
metagenome profile
so here are the equations for
calculating each of these classification
evaluation metrics accuracy is the ratio
of correct predictions to all
predictions
Precision is the ratio of true positives
to predicted positives and this is most
relevant when there is a high cost for
having false positives
sensitivity is the ratio of true
positives to actual positives or the
true positive rate
and this is most relevant when concerned
with identifying positive outcomes and
the cost to a false positive is low
specificity on the other hand is the
ratio of true negatives to actual
negatives and the this is the true
negative rate and this is most relevant
when concerned with accuracy of negative
of the negative rate
and there is a high cost for a positive
outcome and finally F1 scores the
harmonic mean of precision and
sensitivity and it takes both false
positives and false negatives into
account
so this figure shows an overview of the
results from performance analysis and
included here is a shuffled null data
set which represents completely random
Gene abundances generated by chance with
no biological significance and this was
generated by shuffling Gene abundance
counts within samples and then across
samples and this was repeated 10 times
and it's used as a baseline comparison
for results due to chance
for spearman's correlation we expect the
Spearman correlation of the ground truth
and the
um shuffled null data set to be around
zero whereas for accuracy we would
expect it to be around 0.5
from this figure I won't go into all of
the um specific plots within this figure
but I just wanted to point out that we
observed extremely high sensitivity
coupled with extremely poor Precision
here and this indicated to us that we
might have inflated false positive
counts and this was confirmed by taking
a closer look at the confusion matrices
and we found that pan FP had a false
positive count of greater than 4 000
which was much greater than any other
count and led us to suspect that
spurious Gene abundance predictions may
be present and prompted the decision to
evaluate different filtering thresholds
for Gene abundance counts in Med genome
profiles or predictions
this table shows an overview of the
results from comparing the performance
analysis at different filtering
thresholds here we can see that we
observed a significant increase in
spearman's correlation accuracy
precision and specificity for both
paprika and pan FP whereas we just
observed a decrease in sensitivity but
this was expected since filtering
decreases the number of positive
predictions and sensitivity measures the
ratio of positive predictions
we also see that there is no significant
change in performance for pie crust 2.
we confirmed these Trends by taking a
look at the false positive counts after
filtering and we noticed that the false
positive counts decrease substantially
after filtering for both paprika and pan
FP so paprika decreased by around 300
whereas pan FP decreased by around 1700
and this decrease was reflected in an
increase in the negative the false neg
or the true negative counts for both
paprika and pan FP where essentially all
of the
um all of the occurrences of false
positives were transferred to True
negatives
and these results indicate that Gene
abundance count filtering effectively
improved performance by removing
potentially spurious results
so now this figure shows an overview of
the performance results for metagenome
profiles with Gene abundance counts
filtered at a threshold of one
and
um
each of these metrics that are
represented here describes a different
aspect of performance and while they're
all helpful and informative there are
certain metrics that are more relevant
for this investigation the first being
spearmans as this was used to confirm
the efficacy of the shuffled null data
set
accuracy is also important because we're
concerned with correctly identifying
present and absent genes
sensitivity is important because we're
concerned with identifying all
potentially present genes and do not
necessarily care about false positives
as it's more important to identify
potentially present genes than
misidentifying a gene as being present
however
F1 takes into account the false positive
rate and while we're concerned with
identifying all potentially present
genes and don't necessarily care about
false positives we don't want our
results to be too heavily skewed by
false positive so F1 takes into account
the false positive right and that's why
it's important for this investigation
so we'll first take a look at the
results from spearman's correlation
analysis and this is indicates the
association between predictions in the
ground truth and as I mentioned earlier
this mainly serves as a confirmation
that shuffling for the shuffled null
data set was successful as we would
expect to see very little correlation
with the ground Truth for completely
random data set and that's exactly what
we see so here and here and here and
here we can see that the spearman's
correlation between the shuffled null
data sets and the ground truth was
essentially zero as expected and it
indicates that this these data sets
serve their intended purpose
we can also see from this figure that
pie crust 2 exhibits significantly
greater correlation with the ground
truth than other metagenomic inference
tools and all tools exhibit
significantly greater correlation with
the ground truth than the shuffled null
data set which indicates that
associations between each metagenomic
inference tool and the ground truth are
biologically relevant
next we can take a look at accuracy
analysis
and we observed some varying Trends in
accuracy across the different cohorts so
we'll start by looking at the Diablo and
cohort and in this cohort we see that
paprika exhibits significantly greater
accuracy than Pi crust 2 in terms of EC
term or EC numbers and since both tools
exhibited significantly greater accuracy
than the shuffled null data set we can
assume that this finding is biologically
relevant
however for KO terms both tools exhibit
significantly less accuracy than the
shuffled null data set in terms of ko
terms and this indicates that KO term
predictions are less accurate than by
chance in this specific cohort
moving on to the gestational age cohort
we see again that paprika exhibits
significantly greater accuracy than Pi
crust 2 in terms of EC numbers and both
tools exhibit significantly greater
accuracy or yeah accuracy than the
shuffled null data set so we can assume
that this finding is biologically
relevant
as for KO terms we see that pan FP
exhibits significantly greater accuracy
than both pie crust 2 and the shuffled
node data set in terms of ko terms and
we see that pie crust 2 actually
performs worse than the shuffled null
data set in terms of accuracy for KO
terms and this indicates that again for
this cohort that pie crust 2 predictions
are less accurate than by chance
finally we can take a look at the
resonance cohort and in this cohort we
see that all predictions are better than
have greater significantly greater
accuracy than the shuffled null data set
which tells us that these findings are
biologically relevant and we see that
pie crust 2 exhibits significantly
greater accuracy than Paprika in terms
of EC numbers whereas pan FP exhibits
significantly greater accuracy than pie
crust 2 in terms of ko terms
we can interpret these results as being
that accuracy for each tool varies
depending on the cohort being analyzed
however we do see
um some Trends where paprika exhibits
significantly greater accuracy than Pi
crust 2 in terms of EC numbers and
two-thirds of the cohorts whereas pan FP
exhibits significantly greater accuracy
than pie crust 2 in all of the cohorts
except that in the first cohort both
exhibited significantly less than the
shuffled null data set so we can't
really use that in our findings
so now we'll take a look at the
sensitivity analysis and this measures
the true positive rate and here we
observe the same Trends across all the
cohorts that we investigated so for all
cohorts Pi crust 2 exhibits
significantly greater
sensitivity for each genome annotation
type and since each tool exhibits
significantly greater sensitivity than
the shuffled mode data set we can assume
that these findings are biologically
relevant
we can interpret these results as pie
crust 2 predicting more genes as being
present compared to other tools however
since pie crust 2 was unaffected by Gene
abundance count filtering this could be
an artifact of inflated false positive
counts and this actually appears to be
the case especially for KO terms where
the false positive count greatly
exceeded all other counts
so while we're concerned with
identifying all potentially present
genes we don't want the majority of
those genes to be misidentified which is
the case here so pie crust 2's greater
sensitivity does not necessarily
correlate to improved performance for
these cohorts
so finally we can take a look at the F1
score which is the harmonic mean of
precision and sensitivity and as I
mentioned earlier takes both the false
negative and false positive counts into
consideration
we observed some trends that were
consistent across all cohorts and
specifically for KO terms where pan FP
exhibits significantly greater accuracy
or F1 than
um pie crust 2 in all of in terms of ko
terms for all the cohorts
additionally all predictions were
significantly greater than the shuffled
null data set for each genome annotation
type indicating that all these findings
are biologically relevant
as for EC numbers we see that in the
diademium cohort there is no significant
difference in between paprika and pie
crust 2 in terms of EC numbers whereas
in both the gestational age cohort and
the resonance cohort we see that pie
crust 2 exhibits significantly greater
F1 than Paprika in terms of EC numbers
these results can be interpreted as pan
FP accurately predicts more genes as
being present than pie crust 2 in terms
of ko terms and pie crust 2 accurately
predicts more genes as being present
than Paprika in terms of EC numbers
so next we can take a look at the
results from differential abundance
agreement analysis and this measures the
overlap of or the agreement of
differentially abundant genes identified
in both the metagenome profile and the
metagenome predictions and I used a
chi-squared test to test for the
significance of disagreement this
analysis sheds light on the predictive
power of metagenomic inference tools and
specifically evaluates whether results
from differential abundance analysis
based on wgs can be replicated using
metagenomic inference
so these are the results from
differential abundance agreement
analysis the top tables represent the
counts of differentially abundant genes
that were identified by each tool
whereas the bottom represents a um the
agreement analysis so as we can see in
both the diab immune cohort and the
gestational age cohort we don't see any
we didn't find any differentially
abundant genes that were produced by any
of the predictions or the metagenome
profiles and while this is a slightly
striking result it's not necessarily
that surprising based on the results of
our exploratory data analysis where we
compared the taxonomic composition
between test groups in each of these
cohorts and in this Eda we did not
identify any significant difference in
taxonomic composition between the test
groups in the diademium cohort or in the
gestational age cohort however we did
identify a significant difference in
taxonomic composition in the resonance
cohort and this was reflected in the
fact that we did identify differentially
abundant genes also
here we identified 14 genes as being
significantly differentially abundant by
wgs using EC number genome annotations
we also identified 119 genes as being
differentially abundant using pi crust 2
in terms of EC numbers
and 394 genes as being significantly
differentially abundant for paprika
of these genes that were identified as
being significantly differentially
abundant one from pie crust overlapped
with wgs whereas four from paprika
overlapped with wgs and this resulted in
a Kappa value of essentially zero which
um
indicates that agreement was no better
than by chance for this
and finally now we can take a look at
the computational resource requirements
analysis and this just compared memory
requirements in terms of RAM and dis and
storage requirements in terms of disk
space
so here we can see that wgs processing
using human three required far more
computational resources than any of the
metagenomic inference tools within the
metagenomic inference tools pie crust 2
had the most computational resource
requirements followed by paprika and
then finally by pan FP
so now we can discuss what these results
actually mean
first I just wanted to introduce the
functional analysis decision framework
that was generated based on the results
of this investigation and this was
generated as a means of helping
investigators choose a functional
analysis strategy that best suits the
needs for their specific project
um so when we decide that we want to do
functional analysis our first decision
that we need to make is what is our
desired functional output if Gene
content as our desired functional output
then we have a choice between two
different approaches
the first being metagenomic infra or
metagenomics which is done using wgs and
the second being metagenomic inference
the deciding factor here is the cost and
the confidence of attaining results so
um for metagenomics we have high
confidence in our results but also high
cost in attaining those results whereas
if we're more concerned with the cost of
attaining results and we're not
necessarily as concerned about the
confidence in the results as we would be
in an exploratory analysis that's going
to be validated anyway then we can use
metagenomic inference and deciding
between the metagenomic inference tools
really comes down to the genome
annotation type that's being used so if
we want to use KO terms then we can use
um pet or pan FP however we identified
that KO terms are subject to spurious
results
if we want EC numbers as our genome
annotation type then paprika can be used
additionally we if we want multiple
genome annotation choices then we should
use pie crust 2 and we can also we can
use pie crust 2 to generate KO term
predictions and EC number predictions as
I mentioned earlier and another factor
that plays into this decision is the
computational resource requirements so
we observe increasing requirements
across these three so pan FP has
requires the least amounts of
computational resources followed by
paprika and then pie crust 2 requires
the most
if gene expression content is our
desired functional output then we really
only have one option and that's to carry
out meta transcriptomics and this is
using rna-seq
the same goes for protein content we
really only have one option and that's
to carry out meta proteomics however we
do have a choice between what tools we
want to use to carry out metaprio mix so
we can either use normal Mass Spec or a
newer version of mass spec liquid
chromatography Mass Spec and this just
results in higher confidence results
and finally if metabolite content is our
desired functional output we again have
the choice between metabolomics or
metabolic model inference and this again
the deciding factor here is cost and
confidence so if we're really concerned
with having high confidence in our
results then we want to carry out
metabolomics and this is done using mass
spec or nuclear magnetic resonance
spectroscopy
whereas if we're not necessarily
concerned with the confidence in our
results but we really are concerned with
the cost of attaining those results like
we would be in an exploratory analysis
then we can carry out metabolic model
inference and there's one tool available
to do this right now and that's a tool
called mycom
so as I've kind of alluded to earlier
metagenomic inference has some
limitations the first being that it does
not provide evidence all the findings
that we get from a genomic inference do
need to be validated to draw relevant
conclusions from it but this doesn't
discount the use of metagenomic
inference as it can be really helpful
for orienting researchers towards
expected results and this can be helpful
for grant writing or hypothesis forming
or other activities like that
additionally metagenomic inference is
susceptible to errors resulting from
horizontal Gene transfer and this is
because we're relying on the reference
databases to predict the metagenome
content or the genomes of the microbes
that are present in the gut and we're
not actually measuring what's going on
within the gut and this means that if
there's horizontal Gene transfer between
microbes that's happening within the gut
of a specific individual and that's not
reflected in the reference database then
we're not going to be able to capture
that horizontal Gene transfer
additionally metagenomic inference
relies on reference databases and this
means that we're limited to those
microbes that are represented in these
reference databases and this can cause
issues if we're investigating
environments that are not well reflected
in these reference databases like the
Pediatric microbiome or other microbial
environments that aren't necessarily as
studied as the adult gut microbiome for
example
and finally metagenomic inference does
not predict metagenome contribution from
all domains and this is because it
relies on 16s RNA sequencing which is
only capable of capturing bacteria and
archaea
there are also some specific limitations
to my analysis plan the first being that
I relied on default reference databases
and there were some differences between
the default reference databases that
were used by each of these tools and
also for each of these tools the
reference databases that were provided
by default
there are more current versions
available for each of these
additionally I relied on publicly
available data
which resulted in gaps in age as well as
gaps in representation of different
diets and gaps in representation of
different ethnicities and all of these
factors are known to have a significant
effect on the composition of the gut
microbiome
additionally there were discrepancies
between genome annotation types as I
mentioned earlier so pan FP produced
genome prediction metagenome predictions
in terms of ko terms whereas paprika
produced those predictions in terms of
EC numbers making it impossible to
directly compare paprika to pan FP
however we used Pi crust as a sort of
proxy for comparison between the two
and finally this being a master's thesis
I was subject to time and computational
constraints
um given more time and expanded data
sets could have been utilized which
could have resulted in more conclusive
results as well as some more nuanced
investigations
so we can draw some
um we definitely can draw some
conclusions from this investigation the
first being that metagenomic inference
does serve as a cost-effective
alternative to metagenome profiling for
exploratory analyzes in the Pediatric of
microbiome and there's an asterisk here
because as I mentioned before results
from exploratory analysis based on my
genomic inference do need to be
validated using other methods before
conclusions can be drawn
additionally we observed High
variability in the performance of
metagenomic inference tools specifically
results from performance analysis vary
depending on the data set being analyzed
as well as the genome annotation type
used and the metric being compared
we also see that KO term genome
predictions were subject to inflated
false positive counts and
um we also
um observed disagreement with previous
benchmarking specifically benchmarking
done by the pie crust 2 developers in
which they reported that pie crust 2
performs better than pan FP they didn't
include Paprika in their investigation
but
um this disagreement is likely due to
the fact that we're surveying a
different environment as well as the
fact that they didn't carry out any Gene
abundance count filtering in the
previous
um benchmarking and in our investigation
by filtering Gene abundance counts at a
threshold of one we effectively removed
spurious results and deflated the false
positive count for pan FP
So based on these conclusions I came up
with three recommendations for
metagenomic inference so if pie crust 2
is being used then EC number genome
annotations should be used rather than
KO term genome annotations and this is
because of the issue with false
positives and spurious results
additionally if using pan FP then Gene
abundance counts Gene abundance count
filtering at a threshold of one should
be considered
and finally if KO term genome
annotations are desired then pan FP
should be used rather than Pi crust 2
based on the results from performance
analysis
all right so that's all I had this is my
references and then are there any
questions
and also
um I'm going to transfer over to the
um
to the microphone in the actual room so
you might hear some static going on
I couldn't hear if anyone said anything
so if you had a question please repeat
it
so thank you Matt
um
if anyone has any questions that are
online
um please
let me know by reason your hand
um and we
or you can just unmute yourself and
start talking
um so really nice job does anybody
that's in person here have a question
and the committee members if you have
more detailed questions we can get into
that after in the private one but um
yeah if you want to go ahead Jenny
um so thank you for a great presentation
thank you and I noticed a lot of
um you took a lot of input so that's
great
um so in your analysis plan you noted
limitations and one of the things you
said is you know limited like ethnicity
or maybe accounting for that
um can you just say a little bit about
gut microbiome differences
so there have been I like I said before
it's really hard to pinpoint specific
normal or healthy compositions for
different populations however there is a
lot of heterogeneity between different
populations and that ethnicity different
ethnicities is not excluded from that so
um there are specific microbes that are
definitely more present in specific
ethnicities and also based on ethnicity
can also is kind of related to
um
related to diet in certain times and
diet really has a huge
on what microbes are present in the
microbiome however there is some
agreement in the genes that are produced
by these microbes so they're we do
observe pretty similar functionality but
we there are differences in specific
microbes
do you have any questions
um I know you mentioned that the data
you were using they were separated into
groups that were being compared
um can you talk a little bit about the
way that you grouped that one data set
um that was not grouped and how
did that all works yeah definitely so
um
because the gut microbiome Begins the
colonization begins at Birth and
continues until
um the onset of puberty I made the
assumption that there would probably be
differences in the taxonomic composition
at different time points within that
range that was represented by that um
study and we actually found that to be
true so
um we use the median to just essentially
split the two the whole data set in half
and
um since we used age we could we would
expect to see uh at least a little bit
of a difference between the two test
groups but between older and younger and
that's exactly what we saw so that's why
I decided to use median age as my um
kind of threshold
thank you
um now I have a question because when
you were showing a lot of your accuracy
and sensitivity results a lot of the
um a lot of the results with the KO
terms I believe it was
um they showed the same Trend in two of
your cohorts but not in one and the one
that was different was always diab
immune is there something specific about
that cohort that makes the predictions a
little less accurate or do you have any
thoughts on why that tended to be the
case so
um I guess there's a couple reasons why
that could be the case so the diabenium
cohort the subjects in the dabbing
cohort were by far the youngest subjects
that were identified so there could be
because it's only care it represented
children from it followed children from
age zero to three so there it isn't
necessarily that surprising that there
wouldn't be that much of a change
um within the composition between the
ages of zero and three just because it's
a pretty narrow time frame but there's
also other things that can contribute to
it the fact that it's all individuals
from Finland which is a kind of a
special case they the um Scandinavian
countries are pretty known to be a
almost um had like a Founder Effect type
deal where they'll um they show
different results than other types of
populations
um and then also the antibiotic
intervention could have had some um
some impact on what is happening
thank you
um are there any questions from everyone
that's online
or anyone that's online
I see that Karen has a question can you
unmute and ask it
um to my presentation from that and I
guess I would just ask you to think
forward if you were to extend This
research to put forward some
recommendations but in what direction
would you go if you were going to
continue this reason
so first I would include way more data
sets I would include expanded data sets
um as I mentioned I did take a subset of
some of these data sets and this was
just to accommodate the computational
and time constraints that I was under I
would definitely include expanded data
sets which could result in more
conclusive results I would also do some
different analyzes I would probably use
a more stringent or nuanced approach for
differential abundance analysis because
I used a pretty basic approach for this
and I think that I could potentially see
better results more conclusive results
using a type of differential abundance
analysis that maybe takes
um prior knowledge into account like a
Bayesian approach or one that adjusts
for or accounts for covariates or even
in the microbiome we deal with very
sparse data so that could have a big
effect on it too so filtering
oh that's very helpful and maybe I
noticed that you may have shown it did
you show like area under curves when you
were looking talking about uh accuracy
no I didn't I didn't include the area
under the curve but um that is kind of
represented in the F1 score but that is
that's another thing that I would do I
would um improve I would include some
expanded performance metrics and
um do a more Deep dive into the actual
differences in computational resource
requirements uh there are plenty of
other different types of um analyzes
that I could have done
um additionally I could try to
um one thing that I have recently been
considering is the fact that pie crust 2
was not responsive to the filtering
whereas at what we still saw a lot of
spurious results for the KO terms so
evaluating more stringent
um
thresholds for filtering may result in
better results for pie crust 2 in terms
of ko turns but in general I would I
would probably lean away from using KO
terms uh one because they it's not it's
a proprietary database now it was at one
point open source but now it's
proprietary which is one of the reasons
why the databases haven't been updated
in a while as well
additionally I would also probably
include a custom databases because that
could probably get better results
thank you
so are there any more questions from the
folks online I do not see any
um anyone here right
[Music]
um
not specifically I besides what I
alluded to earlier the fact that we
didn't really see any taxonomic
differences in or taxonomic composition
differences between the cohorts um that
definitely could result in
differences and we did see that I
believe the diapamune and the
gestational age cohort were more similar
than the resonance cohort um and that
probably that could be a result from the
fact that there's not really that big of
a difference between taxonomic
composition and but it also could be a
result of the fact that we could be
slightly underpowered for this effect
size with this sample size that we're
using
all right and then okay I guess that was
my next question
um I I would definitely need to look
back and do some more analysis I do
think that we did set we did
to observe what we kind of set out to
see which was can we replicate the
results from wgs in um with metagenomic
inference however I definitely think
that using uh more nuanced approach for
uh differential abundance probably would
have resulted in more
um conclusive results definitely
deal with some common critiques of the
parental abundance of yeah yeah so as I
mentioned earlier there's the sparsity
is an issue so um the fact that in
metagenome profiles we see a lot of
genes as being and even in just normal
relative abundance of specific microbes
for comparing the differential abundance
of that we see very sparse data where
we'll see lots of microbes having zero
abundance and these can really skew the
um if specifically for our investigation
we were comparing I used a Wilcox and
rank sum test to just compare the
distributions and these were heavily
skewed by the fact that there were a lot
of zeros present
great thank you um if there's no more
questions from the online audience
um we will end
the meeting and then that will stay for
um meeting with his committee members
thank you thanks everyone